[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous recevons pauline
d'orgeval présidente et cofondatrice de
kohat petit santé une association qui
agit en faveur de l'accès aux soins pour
tous en prenant en compte les besoins
des personnes les plus vulnérables
madame d'hors jeu valable bienvenue sur
rt franjou expliquez-nous qui sont ces
personnes vulnérables alors le le
pratiquent même de notre association
c'est de réduire les inégalités d'accès
à la santé et d'accès aux soins
et c'est vrai que on se rend compte que
les personnes en situation de handicap
notamment ont été largement oublié de
beaucoup de politiques en santé et donc
je finisse par renoncer au soir renoncer
à les voir des médecins parce que rien
n'est fait penser pour pouvoir
accueillir dans de bonnes conditions
voilà donc les personnes fragiles on va
dire que pour répondre à votre question
c'est évidemment les personnes en
situation de handicap quel que soit le
handicap parce qu'il n'ya pas un
handicap ya plein de types de handicaps
évidemment possible toutes les personnes
en situation de précarité
parce que souvent elles s'excluent
elle-même elle renonce aussi aux soins
et puis voilà par extension évidemment
toutes les personnes âgées c'est le même
mécanisme dans tellement d'autres
priorités que souvent le elle renonce
elle reçoit alors cette période actuelle
d'épidémie que nous vivons est difficile
à vivre difficile à comprendre même plus
pour certaines personnes polyhandicapées
c'est là que vous intervenez vous avez
proposé deux posters en falck fall que
ça veut dire
facile à lire facile à comprendre
expliquez-nous un peu ce que c'est alors
déjà la période est en effet très
compliqué à vivre parce que
c'est difficile de parler pour tous les
types de handicap mais les structures
médico sociales ont bien souvent fermés
et beaucoup de beaucoup de familles se
sont retrouvées finalement à s'occuper à
seul à temps plein deux de leurs enfants
parfois du temps avec un handicap très
lourd et donc ça a été vraiment
compliqué pour beaucoup de personnes
avec un handicap qui aussi avait moins
de monde que d'habitude et beaucoup
beaucoup de familles donc dans cette
dans cette période
ce qu'a fait notre association puisqu'en
fait peut-être je vais commencer par
présenter l'association l'association
elle essaye d'agir concrètement sur
l'accès aux soins des personnes en
situation de handicap avec un outil qui
s'appelle santé bd et qui permet
finalement à l'aide d'illustrations et à
l'aide de phrases très simple qu'on
appelle est ce que vous avez dit du fac
du français facile à lire et à
comprendre de permettre à tous y compris
des personnes avec déficience
intellectuelle ou avec autisme ou qui
parle pas bien français de comprendre ce
qui se passe de comprendre le type de
consultation le déroulé d'une
consultation ou le déroulé d'un acte
comme la radio lille et rennes et c'est
donc là dedans et dans ce prolongement
dans le prolongement de ce projet
naturellement avec cette période qu vide
et d'abord cette première période de
confinement eh ben on a fait des posters
sur ce qu'était le confinement les
gestes barrières comme le savent les
mains comment on continue à attaquer les
activités ont peu à voir prendre dans le
confinement comment on peut aller faire
ses courses en toute sécurité
on a vraiment essayé d'expliquer
simplement à tous en bas ce qui était
possible de faire et
et comment on pouvait le faire alors
nous voilà donc ça saigne et au projet
et un autre projet mais je peux être on
y reviendra
c'est andy connect point fr est là c'est
vraiment des fiches conseils à
destination des médecins et plus
largement des professionnels de santé
pas pour accueillir pour leur donner des
billes pour accueillir dans de bonnes
conditions des personnes avec avec avec
différents types de handicap puisque
évidemment on n'accueille pas du tout de
la même façon une personne
polyhandicapée qu'une personne
voilà qui n'a pas de handicap et pas du
tout de la même façon de personnes
polyhandicapées qu'une personne autiste
ou une personne avec déficience
intellectuelle ou déficience visuelle ou
auditive
voilà les deux projets alors c'est
parfois compliqué pour les personnes
polyhandicapées de respecter les gestes
barrière est-ce que vous avez constaté
une crainte au niveau des auxiliaires de
vie ou des personnels soignants qui se
déplace justement au domicile de ces
personnes atteintes de polyhandicap
alors oui c'est difficile pour les
personnes avec polyhandicap mais c'est
difficile aussi pour des idées dépassées
des personnes avec déficience
intellectuelle ou avec autisme
voilà pour pour beaucoup de ces
personnes avec handicap c'est difficile
et donc clairement il ya eu dans des
structures médico sociales des personnes
qui qui se mettaient en arrêt de travail
ou qu'ils exerçaient leur droit de
retrait et puis de la même façon il ya
eu beaucoup d'intervenants
d'accompagnants qui n'ont pas souhaité
aller au domicile alors que comme je le
disais les familles bien souvent ont
récupéré leur leurs enfants ou alors en
sens inverse des familles qui n'avaient
pas confiance dans les intervenants
extérieurs puisque vous l'avez dit elles
font partie quand même de ces personnes
fragiles et et ne respectons pas n'étant
pas toujours en capacité de respecter
les
gestes barrières peut-être plus jean
king que d'autres attraper le corona
games
donc oui ça a eu un effet important sur
la peur de les accompagnants pendant
pendant cette période de confinement et
je pense que ça ça continue même si ben
maintenant il ya des masques
maintenant voilà tout se met en place
pour accompagner dans la durée passée
que le virus va durer alors c'est un
grand débat pour la réouverture des
crèches et des écoles notamment un bozic
de faire respecter les east barrières
par les enfants dans les centres
spécialisés ou des personnes atteintes
de troubles autistiques ou alors de
déficience intellectuelle cohabitent
comment concrètement ça se passe ben
c'est un peu toute là toute la
difficulté vont voir si je prends le
calme en fils impossible de lui faire
mettre un masque n'est impossible
donc comme je le disais les gestes
barrière peuvent parfois ne tout
simplement ne pas être appliquée donc
c'est un casse tête pour les
établissements ou pour les familles pour
les familles on va dire que le cofam
mais dans les deux cas on va dire que
c'est une sorte de confinement qui
perdure parce que même si ils ont
théoriquement la possibilité de sortir à
partir du moment où ils peuvent pas
forcément respecter la loi et même si la
loi prend en compte que ces personnes
n'ont pas forcément sont pas forcément
obligé de mettre des masses la loi a
vraiment pris en compte toutes les
spécificités des personnes en situation
de handicap
la conséquence de tout ça c'est bien
souvent on les confine dans leur
établissement où ils sont confinés dans
leurs familles et donc le compliment
risque de risque de durer en revanche au
niveau des intervenants
extérieur voilà un mystère que ces
voiliers reviennent quand même dans les
familles dans les établissements mais
c'était plus petits groupes par exemple
quand il ya des ramassages par des
voitures qui viennent chercher les
jeunes à domicile pour les hantent les
amener à leur établissement va
clairement maintenant cdc des trajets
individuels
donc c'est presque un plus pour la
personnes avec handicap
et puis les établissements d'accueil
mais comme les écoles des effectifs plus
léger donc paradoxalement il ya
peut-être plus d'accompagnants par
personne accueillie qui est évidemment
une bonne chose parce que bon c'est
qu'il ya besoin beaucoup de danse
d'encadrement et d'accompagnement alors
on le disait en début d'interview vous
avez réalisé deux posters en fallait
pour expliquer le confinement aux
personnes en difficulté ensuite vous
avez également aidé le secrétariat
d'état chargé des personnes handicapées
a réalisé des affiches pour expliquer ce
qu'était le déconfinement aux personnes
en difficulté mais vous avez également
vous disiez créer des fiches à
destination du personnes médicale parce
que les personnes atteintes de
polyhandicap ont bien évidemment besoin
d'un suivi spécifique quand elles vont à
l'hôpital
oui alors effectivement tout l'enjeu de
notre association c'est pas faire nos
fiches dans notre coin et de co
construire les fiches avec les acteurs
associatifs institutionnels donc
donc on peut dire qu'on a aidé le
secrétariat d'état aux personnes
handicapées mais mais plutôt que ils
nous ont sollicités pour travailler
ensemble sur des sur des fiches donc
d'une part effectivement une fiche
qu'est ce qui va se passer le 11 mai en
gros le déconfinement cette fois les
puis une autre fiche vraiment
importantes sur l'auto détermination
pour que la personne avec un handicap
puis choisir elle même s'ils restent
confinés où si elle reprend par exemple
des activités si elle va ou alors
ressortir
donc voilà ça a été vraiment un travail
collaboratif avec le secrétariat d'état
aux personnes handicapées avec le fc ph
et puis et puis dans tout doux les
membres du groupe de travail de
l'association
et puis comme vous le disiez donc par
andy connect point fr on a été soliste
est là pour dépôt des fiches au départ
par exemple sur les urgences
puisque on se disait que plus fragiles
les personnes avec handicap et notamment
polyhandicap allait se retrouver aux
urgences et les médecins urgentistes et
tout l'encadrement des urgences il
fallait absolument qu'ils soient
sensibilisés au sujet et qui puisse
accompagner accueillir soignés dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
donc voilà on a créé une fiche sur jean
sur le polyhandicap et puis au fur et à
mesure on est en train de de créer des
fiches sur les patients avec suspicion
covin pour tous les patients pas pour
tous les types de handicap parce que je
le répète accueillir une personne
autiste ou accueillir une personne
déficiente visuelle ou polyhandicapés ça
n'a rien à voir
et voilà il était important que les
soignants soient sensibilisés à ces
sujets alors très rapidement madame
orgeval concilier kobe 19 et
polyhandicap notamment c'est très
compliqué peut-être un conseil pour tous
les aidants qui vont nous regarder je
moi je me permettrai pas de donner des
conseils
moi ce que je peux que je peux dire
c'est que cette cette crise du colis dès
ce confinement ont permis de réaliser à
tel point à quel point les aidants sont
essentielles finalement la personne en
situation de handicap ce confinement
finalement tout reposer sur elle et donc
moi ce que je le message que j'ai envie
de dire c'est bravo parce qu'il ya
vraiment énormément de deux parents qui
ont été incroyables pendant ce
confinement
et puis dire à quel point c'est
important aussi d'avoir des solutions de
répit parce que on a tous besoin on peut
pas porter durablement même si les
structures médico sociales se sont
réinventés on merci on a pu avoir accès
à des de la télémédecine du thé les
soins de la télé qui naît de la danse à
distance voilà tout le monde a été
formidable mais beaucoup de choses ont
reposé sur les aidants et donc d'en
démultiplier les solutions de répit
madame georges van merci d'avoir été
avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes co
fondatrice et présidente de co actis
santé merci vous l'aurez compris c'est
la fin de six une de cette interview
merci de nous avoir suivi une grande
interview à retrouver sur notre site
internet
rt france pour tv merci see a très vite
je
[Musique]